stop saying I can't when you say I can't
you remove possibilities from your life
that could have a tremendous positive
impact on where you go when you say I
can't you shut doors you limit yourself
and you limit the business that you can
create for yourself I recently came back
from a Carnival cruise and I met the DJ
in the elevator on the first day I was
so excited because I'm a big dancer I
love salsa music I'm an investor in a
salsa company here in Toronto and I'm a
DJ dancer sometimes teaching I love
salsa bachata kizomba all the Latin
dances and I'm excited that the DJ's on
the elevator with me I wanted to pick
his brain see what he had plain ask for
some songs and he said he played sauce a
plate bachata and they said you play
kizomba in his own was a dancer that
we're teaching now here in Toronto and I
wanted to practice I wanted to get my
kazoomba on and he said no I can't and
that was the end of the conversation and
I think what do you mean you can't how
hard is it to find one kizomba song and
play it tonight it'll take five minutes
go online find one song and play it
better yet ask me hey that's a great
idea I don't usually play kizomba but
I'll play one for you tonight what's
your favorite kizomba song how hard
would that have been and instead of me
slamming the guy and saying what bad
service carnival provides I'd be
praising them and saying hey what a
great example of customer service he
would have made an impact on my vacation
on my experience with that company just
by limiting the word I can't it's so
important when somebody says I can't to
you how do you feel you feel like you're
out of options you feel upset you feel
hopeless you do not want your customers
and your prospects feeling that way
about your business I don't even blame
the guy
I blame carnival because that's bad
training everybody on that boat needs to
know never to say I can't to a customer
this is a service-based business it's
all about service provide good service
it's not that difficult and I know what
you're thinking hey it's hard you know
maybe the guys really busy maybe doesn't
want to step outside the box maybe he's
got a lot on his plate and fine we're
all busy I'm busy you're busy but busy
is not enough this would have taken five
minutes and had a massive impact on how
I thought about him and the company you
have to go that extra mile if you don't
you're going to be forgettable and
people won't come back and they won't
talk about you stop spending your money
on advertising and marketing and invest
in the customer experience every
experience with your business should be
fantastic amazing make me want to come
back and do more with you that's where
your time and effort should go because
that will help spread the word and get
repeat business coming to you so some
action items some steps for you what to
do next the next time somebody says can
you do something and before you say i
can if you're thinking i can't pause
breathe take two minutes and try to
think of a way that you can just think
outside the box this is not what you
typically do you may not provide that
exact product or service but just humor
me and take two minutes to try to find a
solution when your brain is set on
finding something often it will surprise
you and find it so just stop yourself
for two minutes and think about it okay
number two step number two find the
closest thing that you can do to help
them if you can't help this customer
with exactly what they want find the
closest thing that you can
do to help them and show them that you
care that's what it's all about at the
end of the day if you can actually help
them it's fine but you want them walking
away thinking like you tried everything
you could to help them not to get their
money but to help them don't try to
settle on something they don't need find
the closest thing that you can do for
them and show them you're thinking
outside the box say you know we don't
really do this but here's an idea that
might work for you and give them the
best closest option that you can find
and step three if that doesn't work if
you if you have nothing absolutely
nothing then pass them on to a
competitor pass them on to another
company that you know can help them even
that means giving them to your
competition because the customer will
walk away feeling great about your
business they'll feeling great about you
or your employee and they'll wanna come
back and spend money with you even if it
didn't work out this time if you sell
them something that they don't need
they're going to be pissed off they're
not going to come back I'm going to tell
their friends about what crappy service
you have but if you pass them on your
competition say hey this is the best
that we can do like I'm thinking outside
the box here this is a closest thing we
can come with but I don't think it's
going to solve you know what you need
your best bet is probably to go down the
street to this company and they can
solve your problem for you they're going
to love that you give them that tip
they're going to love your business is
gonna have nothing but good thoughts if
they have another potentially she
they're going to come back to you and
they're going to tell their friends
about you or make videos like this I
wish somebody gave me that kind of
experience because I would promote them
that's what you need for your business
so eliminate the words I can't from your
vocabulary today and everybody on your
team and you'll start seeing
improvements for your company it's one
small change but has a dramatic impact
on what happens with your company
belief if you like this video you know
the drill thumbs up below thanks guys
and I want to hear we have to think you
liked this video leave a comment
underneath let me know what you're
thinking about if you have a question
for your company leave it below I always
read those I read every single comment
that comes in and i love it always makes
my day so please leave a comment below
thank you i'll see you soon